avant quand j'allais bosser je me je
m'habillais super bien pour aller au
boulot que j'avais des habits un petit
peu plus
stylé là je suis tout le temps tenue de
travaux et tout je suis bien habitué je
trouve canon comme ça
[Musique]
un peu le délire
au naturel tant qu'on se tape pas sur le
système moi ça me va
votre physique vous en avez fait un
métier votre physique Jean-Pascal vous
en avez fait une force
j'aime pas la transition qu'elle a fait
une bombe bon toi tu es moche mais bon
tu as été quand même
oh ça va les têtes de désinformation
c'est pas du tout pour lui hein
c'est lui la lumière de l'équipe
normalement
on a quand même ça reste une chanteuse
on lui a dit c'est le bac elle arrivait
avec une jupe et des couettes bon on est
quand même sur quelqu'un de basique
voilà de toutes les façons j'avais pas
le choix et j'étais grand noir mince des
longues dents qu'est-ce que tu voulais
que je fasse d'autres fallait que
j'utilise le rire pour avancer les
blagues tout ça c'est comme ça que j'ai
eu mes premières meufs c'est comme ça
que j'ai eu mes premiers potes donc j'ai
utilisé la même stratégie pour avoir
pour trouver ma place dans la société
c'est pour être
capitaine
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais vous êtes libre
c'est pas mal
et vous ça fait la ça fait combien
d'années que vous êtes pas obligé comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
le ministère de l'Intérieur lance une
grande campagne pour la sécurité des
femmes dans l'espace public de
prévention qui commence donc aujourd'hui
et qui va durer tous l'été campagne pour
lutter contre le harcèlement de rue dans
son victime les femmes 5 millions de
flyers vont être distribués par des
policiers et des gendarmes pour rappeler
les réflexes à avoir quand on est
victime ou témoin d'une agression ça
permet d'informer les gens on sait que
on a encore 80% des femmes qui sont
victimes qui n'osent pas porter plainte
donc c'est un moyen supplémentaire de
leur donner de l'information sur ces 5
millions de documents qui seront
distribués tout au long de l'été un QR
code dirige sur le site Ma sécurité.fr
pour signaler des violences 24 heures
sur 24 au verso les démarches à suivre
que l'on soit victime ou témoins
vendredi il a un mec qui me sort tu veux
pas être ma [__] pour 2 euros dans le
métro on sent des mains il y a quelqu'un
qui m'a suivi chez moi c'est triste
c'est d'autant que se tourner vers la
police comme le préconise le
gouvernement cela semble inutile à la
trentenaire en rentrant du Nouvel An de
se faire agresser on a été porté plainte
le lendemain il nous en dit ben il y a
pas de coup on peut rien faire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ce rayon scandalise une partie de
l'Amérique
ces articles pro LGBTQ plus son vendus
par les supermarchés target lors du mois
des fiertés événements organisé depuis
10 ans mais cette année ça ne passe pas
un pélo boycott incident dans les
magasins et même rap anti target
[Musique]
musique la plus écoutée sur le iTunes
américains catégorie rap hip-hop
résultat target a retiré certains des
produits provoquant la colère d'autres
clients
c'est un peu réducteur tu vois et donc
moi ce qui me fait rire c'est que les
gens ne s'écoutent pas alors que souvent
il y a des choses intéressantes à
débattre à discuter tout ça mais on
s'écoute plus on se dit ah bah lui c'est
un wok je lui parle pas lui les droites
je parle pas lui c'est un connard bon
connard j'ai extrapoler c'est que je
trouve que on s'écoute pas assez et en
catégorise trop les gens et je trouve
que voilà ça manque d'écoute vous vous
êtes quoi si on devait vous catégoriser
dans une tribune publiée par le journal
Le Monde cette société savante de
médecine la cuve d'avoir prescrit de
l'hydroxychloroquine pendant la crise du
covid sans autorisation et qui était
jugé inefficace ensemble il dénonce un
vaste et ses thérapeutique sauvage mais
le côté Kabbale le côté chasse à l'homme
qui vient de plus en plus en France
c'est assez détestable quand même il
faut avouer
oui mais alors
on va se faire quand vous avez lu La
Tribune vous étiez pas un peu énervé
je l'ai pas lu même pas lui parler un
peu non
vous savez c'est
aucun intérêt moi je n'écoute pas les
gens qui disent du mal de moi je ne les
lis pas et il m'intéresse pas je fais
pareil
j'ai remarqué Dark Vador huer à son
arrivée au tribunal cette scène s'est
déroulée au Chili le méchant dans Star
Wars était sur le banc des accusés pour
avoir coupé la main de son fils un
procès organisé dans le cadre des
Journées du Patrimoine vers dict 30 ans
de congélation une mesure d'éloignement
et interdiction de toucher un sabre
laser les fans des Jedi sont soulagés
mais on se demande si ce tribunal était
compétent pour juger cette affaire c'est
que je vous vois comme ça j'ai une idée
d'émission
allô Didier les gens appellent et pose
des questions sur c'est vrai ça serait
incroyable moi il est hypnotique je peux
rester des heures à le regarder non mais
je vous jure que c'est vrai je le pense
vraiment merci Didier je vous jure moi
je peux vous entendre des heures pour
vous écouter parler pendant des heures
c'est vrai que là je commence à avoir
les fesses qui font bravo moi parce que
il y a quand même tous les critères oui
ça fait comme ça là vous pouvez pas le
voir parce que je suis assis